UK supermarket chain Asda and online
giant Amazon have both slashed the price
of the titanfall bundle of the xbox one
to 349 pounds that's the same price as a
PlayStation 4 i'm mark walton and this
is a money-saving gamespot news update
just weeks after microsoft cut the price
of the xbox one to 399 pounds in the UK
amazon and Asda have dropped the price
of the titanfall bundle to 349 pounds
which is a fairly sizable 50 pound
saving the bundle contains both an Xbox
one and a digital download code for the
online first-person shooter it is by no
means an official price cut from
Microsoft so it is almost inevitable
that the price will returned at 399
pounds at both retailers over the next
couple of days the latest xbox one deal
follows electronic store maplin selling
xbox one stop at 349 pounds at the start
of March but comes with two major
advantages one you get a copy of
titanfall thrown in and to you don't
have to buy anything from Maplin is this
price cut enough to tempt you to pick up
an Xbox one are you miffed that the
price has dropped so quickly after
launch let us know in the comments below
and for all your gaming news keep it
gamespot